resolvamos ahora el problema 151
problemas 151 dice si x y ya son
positivos xy son positivos será cierto
que la razón de x allí es mayor que 3 o
sea lo que nos estamos preguntando es si
x entre y es mayor que 3 muy bien en el
inciso 1 de información lo que nos dicen
es que x es 2 más que 3 veces x es igual
a 3 veces tres veces más 2 quizás
convenga a cambiar esta hipótesis a algo
que se parezca un poco más a esto déjame
multiplicar ambos lados porque nos
quedaría x mayor mayor porque es
positivo verdad entonces no cambia este
signo x mayor a 3 y entonces nos estamos
preguntando esto de aquí x era mayor que
3 ya sí sabemos esto de acá pues claro
que sí verdad aquí nos dice que x
straits y más otra cosa positiva
entonces claramente x le gana
a 3g y por lo tanto este inciso es
suficiente para responder la pregunta
vamos a ver qué nos dice el inciso
número 2
en el inciso número 2 nos dicen que la
razón de 2 x 3 es mayor que 2 2 x 3
es mayor que 2 esto va a ser una
manipulación algebraica verdad a ver
multiplicando por tres desde ambos lados
cosa que podemos hacer porque ya es
positivo nos queda que 2x es mayor que 6
y ahora dividiendo entre dos de ambos
lados como 2 es positivo nos queda que x
es mayor que 3
y eso es justo lo que queríamos
determinar verdad entonces el inciso 2
también es suficiente y por lo tanto la
respuesta es d vamos a pasar ahora el
problema 152 problemas 152 en el
problema 152 nos ponen una semi
circunferencia que voy a dibujar aquí a
ver bueno aquí está una circunferencia
para hacer la semicircunferencia voy a
dibujar este diámetro de acá bueno está
más o menos un diámetro y hay algunos
otros puntos que pone aquí pone punto p
punto q y de este lado punto r
y hay otras cuantas líneas más la pq la
q r y una altura desde q desde cuba
hasta pr y aquí marta marca que este
ángulo es recto
ok creo que ya acabé de dibujar líneas
esta altura dice que mide 2
esta longitud de p a este punto de acá o
sea este cachito dice que mide a y este
cachito de acá dice que mide ve ve muy
bien me parece que eso es todo el dibujo
va ahora la pregunta es si el arco p q r
y forma parte de un semicírculo ok es un
semicírculo cuál es la longitud del
diámetro pr o sea básicamente nos están
preguntando cuál es el valor de a más ve
muy bien en el inciso 1 lo que nos dan
de información es que es igual a 4 a es
igual a 4 y en el inciso 2 lo que nos
dan información es que b es igual a 1 b
es igual a 1
entonces si de alguna forma a partir del
valor de a podemos obtener el valor de b
tendríamos el valor de a b y de manera
similar si con b podemos obtener a
también tendríamos a más b bueno pues
una cosa que que sabemos acerca de los
triángulos que en los cuales uno de los
lados es el diámetro de uno
es que este ángulo de aquí arriba es de
90 grados a lo mejor en el dibujo no lo
parece mucho pero eso siempre se cumple
de hecho es algo que aprendí muchísimo
en competencias de matemáticas pero
bueno quizás después haga un vídeo de
por qué siempre se cumple o a lo mejor
ya tengo uno en mi sección de geometría
puedes revisar pero bueno entonces estoy
acá es de 90 grados y vamos a utilizar
justo eso para determinar cómo están
relacionados a ive déjame ponerle a este
lado de acá se y a este lado de acá de
vamos a empezar notando que pe este
punto y éste son un triángulo rectángulo
porque esto es una altura sale entonces
tenemos que 2 al cuadrado
más al cuadrado es igual a c al cuadrado
aplicando el teorema de pitágoras en
este triángulo de acá y de manera
similar
tenemos que 2 al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado 2 al cuadrado más b al cuadrado
es igual a d al cuadrado sale y ahora lo
que vamos a utilizar es este triángulo
el pq r que es rectángulo con ángulo
recto aquí con este triángulo tenemos
que sea al cuadrado
o sea al cuadrado más de al cuadrado es
igual a todo este lado a b
elevado al cuadrado y esto que nos dice
bueno pues aquí tenemos cuánto vale sea
al cuadrado que es 2 al cuadrado sea 4
masa cuadrada entonces tenemos que
cuatro más a cuadrada más de cuadrada
que es 4 + b cuadrada
4 + b cuadrada es igual a este binomio
al cuadrado vamos a multiplicar lo para
ver que nos queda y cancelar un poco
entonces sería igual a al cuadrado más
dos veces a por b más
b al cuadrado muy bien ahora observa
podemos restar a cuadrada de ambos lados
de cuadrada de ambos lados 4 con cuatro
es 8 entonces nos queda que 8 es igual a
2 veces avn avn y por lo tanto
dividiendo entre 2 de ambos lados
obtenemos que ave es igual a 4 y estoy
aquí está padrísimo porque si además si
a por b es igual a 4 entonces con
cualquiera de estos incisos podemos
obtener un valor a partir del otro por
ejemplo si a es igual a 4 como va por
veces 4 entonces veces 1 y si b es igual
a 1 como va por vez 4 entonces a es
igual a 4 entonces toda esta información
todo este dibujo se redujo a esta
ecuación que nos permite a partir de un
valor encontrar el otro y por lo tanto
con cualquiera de los dos incisos
podemos
la pregunta si sabemos la información de
uno conocemos la información del otro a
partir de esto que acabamos de encontrar
vale bueno y además b sería 5 verdad 4
15 entonces aquí la respuesta sería de
cualquiera de los incisos es bueno para
responder la pregunta vamos ahora al
problema 153
problemas 153 en el problema 153 nos
preguntan si el entero k entero entero
que tendrá algún factor p tiene
tiene
factor
factor p
tal qué
que uno es menor que p que es menor que
acá sale o sea estamos buscando un
divisor mayor que uno y menor que cada
uno y casi siempre son divisores
entonces buscamos un divisor distinto de
esos dos o sea nos estamos preguntando
si chica es primo o más bien si si es no
primo vale o sea esta pregunta de acá es
acá es no primo acá no primo me parece
que se llaman numerosos compuestos
entonces acá es un número compuesto
bueno pues vamos a ver qué información
nos dan en el inciso 1 nos dicen que acá
es mayor que 4 factorial mayor que 4
factorial 4 factorial pues algo
factoriales eso eso me por eso menos 1
por eso menos 2 o sea 4 factorial
es igual a 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 que es
igual a 4 x 3 es 12 por 12 es 24 es
igual a 24 vale entonces esta
información
quiere decir que acá es mayor que 24
pero arriba de 24 podemos encontrar
tanto primos como no primos por ejemplo
el 29 es un número primo y entonces no
tiene factores de esta forma y el 30
pues no es primo no es primo y si tiene
factores de esta forma por ejemplo el 5
verdad el 5 está entre 1 y 30 y divide a
30 entonces esta información no es
suficiente
saleh vamos a bajar un poco más inciso 2
lo que dice el inciso 2 es que 13
factorial 13 factorial más 2 es menor o
igual que acá es menor o igual que acá y
esto es menor o igual que 13 factorial
más 13 ok esto está más interesante
entonces acá está entre 13 factorial más
2 y 13 factorial más 13 bueno pues yo
digo que en este caso acá siempre queda
compuesto déjame primero hacer un
ejemplo y después vemos por qué se vale
para todos los valores de acá por
ejemplo vamos a tomar acá igual a 13
factorial más 2 si acá es 13 factorial
más 2
acá es igual a 13 factorial 2 entonces
podemos escribir que k es igual a 13 por
12 por 11 por y así sucesivamente hasta
por 1 y ya verdad ya eso tenemos que
sumarle dos más dos que es este 2 de acá
pero observa que a por aquí en algún
lugar está el 2 entonces podemos
factorizar un 2 de 13 factorial y nos
queda un entero es decir otra forma de
escribir 13 factorial + 2 es igual es
como como 13 factorial bueno fíjate lo
voy a poner así lo voy a poner como 13
factorial entre 2 por 2 y este más 2 lo
pongo aquí más 2 y este numerito de acá
va a ser un entero porque 13 factorial
tiene al 2 como factor y estoy aquí es
igual a 2 por 13 factorial dividido
entre dos más uno
de esta forma 13 factorial + 2 es un
múltiplo de 2 al dividirlo entre 2 si
pasamos este 2 dividiendo nos queda 13
factorial entre 2 que es entero porque
hay un 2 entre ese factorial más 1
entonces nos quedaría un entero y por lo
tanto 2 es divisor de 13 factorial + 2 y
en general podemos hacer lo mismo para
cualquier cada que quede aquí en medio
cualquier cada quien medios de la forma
voy a cambiar de color para que no sea
tan monótono es de la forma 13 factorial
+ x con x entre 2 y 13 y justo como lo
hicimos aquí podemos escribir esto como
13 factorial por x dividido entre x
más x y aquí podemos factorizar una xy
nos queda x x 13 factorial dividido
entre x más 1 sale esta igualdad la
puedes verificar multiplicando por x de
este lado pero observa si x está entre 2
y 13 entonces x forma parte de 13
factorial está en el producto entonces
esta fracción sería un entero esto sería
un entero y por lo tanto 13 factorial +
x / x es un entero vale es un entero
entonces para cualquier valor de x
resulta que 13 factorial + x es
divisible entre x y justo eso es lo que
nos dice es que 13 factorial + x no es
un número primo vale entonces eso nos
permite responder esta pregunta y por lo
tanto todo esto nos dice que el inciso 2
es suficiente es suficiente para
responder esta pregunta de acá vale muy
bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo